Traductor: Catalina Espinoza Rodríguez
Revisor: Penny Martínez
En 2013, llevaba 15 años
trabajando en una empresa,
que se dedica
a vender material médico-quirúrgico.
La cosa iba bien.
A pesar de la crisis,
los números iban saliendo.
A nivel personal,
mi mujer me seguía aguantando.
Mi hija crecía sana.
Sobre el papel, todo iba bien.
Pero la verdad es que tenía un problema.
Cada mañana me levantaba
y notaba que me crecía una bola
en el estómago.
Algo no iba bien.
Iba a cumplir 40 años.
Y lo peor de esto
no son las primeras canas.
Lo peor
es que me empezaba a aburrir.
A pensar,
¿esto va a ser así siempre?
Comprar, vender, crecer.
¿Para qué?
Había perdido la motivación.
No me veía
otros 25 años haciendo lo mismo.
Así que me puse a buscar. No sabía qué.
Pero dije: "Hay que intentarlo".
Me apunté a toda suerte
de cursos y talleres.
Un día, seis meses después,
un amigo me dijo:
"Esto te va a interesar".
Y tanto que me interesó.
Me enseñó un libro
en el cual los autores decían
que una empresa no solo tenía que servir
a sus clientes y accionistas.
También tenía que cuidar
los intereses de sus empleados.
Al mismo nivel que sus clientes.
Era curioso.
Pero además, tenía que servir
a los intereses de la sociedad.
Tenía que ser
un factor de cambio positivo en el mundo.
Las empresas tenían que cambiar el mundo.
Los autores de ese método de gestión
llamado: "La dirección por misiones",
habían descubierto
que las típicas palancas de motivación
extrínsecas e intrínsecas
que tenemos en las empresas,
no bastaban.
Ellos, a través de un libro pequeño,
habían encontrado una forma sencilla
de impulsar la motivación trascendente
que tenemos todos.
La motivación trascendente
es aquella que nace
cuando nos ponemos
al servicio de los demás.
Un vendedor se puede cansar de vender.
Un administrativo
se puede cansar de pasar pedidos.
Pero ¿a que un bombero, ni se cansa
ni se aburre en medio de un rescate?.
Porque en juego
hay algo más importante que él mismo.
Está al servicio.
Así que empezamos por los empleados.
¿Qué hicimos?
Adoptar una serie de medidas extraídas
de la psicología organizacional positiva.
Coaching personal, coaching de equipo,
mindfulness, desarrollo personal.
Todo esto acabó
en algo extraordinario e imprevisto.
Un edificio optimista.
Me vais a decir:
¿qué es un edificio optimista?
¿Google en Paterna? No puede ser.
No es Google, porque somos una pyme,
y no tenemos el dinero de Google.
Pero hicimos algo diferente.
Cocreamos junto a un artista valenciano
llamado Fernando Jiménez,
y transcribimos todos nuestros sueños,
nuestros valores,
nuestros recuerdos positivos,
en las paredes de nuestro edificio.
Lo transformamos
en el único sitio en España
donde los empleados sienten
que están en su casa.
Porque sus caras,
las de sus mascotas y sus seres queridos
están en las paredes del edificio.
Este edificio nos ayuda
a sentirnos bien y a dar lo mejor.
Esto iba muy bien, pero había otro reto.
Transformar y salvar al mundo.
Un reto sencillo.
Como nos dedicamos a vender catéteres,
sondas para pacientes críticos,
fue sencillo pensar
que íbamos a ayudar a los pacientes.
Queríamos generar
sonrisas en los hospitales.
Más allá de nuestros productos,
hagamos algo para ayudar a los pacientes
a sonreir.
Nos pusimos a buscar y nos dimos cuenta
que en España tenemos muchas ONG's,
muchas asociaciones
que hacen más agradable
la experiencia del paciente.
Nos dimos cuenta rápidamente
de que no podíamos sumar.
Pero en esa busqueda
nos dimos cuenta de una cosa.
Había muy poca gente haciendo algo
para los que cuidan de los pacientes.
Para nuestros cuidadores.
Para nuestros profesionales sanitarios.
Me vais a decir:
"Si el bombero está motivado,
el profesional sanitario, también"
¿acaso necesitan apoyo?
¿Acaso no son profesiones
altamente vocacionales?
¿Una motivación a prueba de bombas?
Pues resulta que no es así.
Resulta que en Estados Unidos,
el 54 % de los médicos especialistas,
no volverían a repetir la misma carrera
si tuvieran la opción de elegir.
El 54 por ciento.
En Inglaterra, han calculado
que si eres mujer y médica,
tienes cuatro veces más posibilidades
de suicidio que cualquier otra persona.
En España, no hay tantos datos.
Quizá no nos queremos asustar.
Pero al igual que en los países vecinos,
sabemos que entre el 30 % y el 50 %
de los profesionales sanitarios
padecen algún tipo de "burnout".
Nuestros profesionales sanitarios
están quemados.
No pueden más.
Y eso tiene un impacto directo
en los pacientes.
¿Cómo nos van a cuidar
si ellos no están bien?
Es imposible.
De hecho, el profesor Michael West
de la Universidad de Lancaster,
ha demostrado que los equipos
en donde no hay comunicación,
no se comparten objetivos
y no hay confianza mutua,
salvan menos vidas
que los equipos que si lo hacen.
El profesor Morales-Quezada
de la Universidad de Boston,
ha demostrado que la empatía del médico
tiene un efecto curativo
sobre el cerebro del paciente.
Ha demostrado,
que si un médico es empático
ayuda a la curación del paciente,
más allá de los medicamentos.
No solo curan los medicamentos.
Claro,
si sabemos esto, y que tenemos por misión
generar más sonrisas en los pacientes,
¿ahora qué? ¿cómo lo hacemos?
Y ahí es cuando inventamos unos premios.
Para llamar la atención.
Para decirle al mundo:
"La salud psicosocial de los hospitales,
es algo muy importante".
Así que creamos
unos premios nacionales en 2015.
Y esos premios nacionales,
han recibido unas 800 candidaturas,
y han servido de inspiración
para la creación de hospitales optimistas.
¿Qué puede ser el optimismo
en una organización sanitaria?
Lo que voy a comentar sobre el optimismo,
vale para la familia, la empresa,
cualquier organización
no solo para un hospital.
El optimismo
es la capacidad de buscar lo positivo
en cualquier situación.
Que no tiene nada que ver
con trabajar de forma alegre,
de forma relajada, el "happiness"...
tiene que ver con buscar lo positivo.
Se puede ser positivo incluso
cuando el barco se está yendo a pique.
Para dejar claro qué es el optimismo,
me puse a escribir un libro.
Para ayudar a nuestros equipos.
Y en ese camino conocí a una persona
que me entendió muy bien,
y que entendió
a nuestros profesionales sanitarios.
Conocí a José Fonseca Pires.
Un portugués,
que era licenciado en Medicina
y doctor en Economía.
Entre los dos descubrimos
cinco rasgos característicos
de una organización sanitaria optimista.
De un hospital optimista.
El primer rasgo:
la capacidad de los "managers"
de entender
que no se puede cuidar a los pacientes
si no se cuida
de los profesionales sanitarios.
Es obvio, pero hay muchos jefes aún
que piensan en los humanos como recursos.
El segundo rasgo:
la seguridad psicológica.
Este es un término acuñado
por la profesora Amy Edmondson
de la Universidad de Harvard.
Y tiene que ver
con la capacidad de los equipos
de generar un clima
en el cual la gente no tenga miedo
de exponer sus dudas en público.
Esa seguridad que se genera
cuando sé aunque no sepa,
puedo comentar en público,
y no voy a quedar en ridículo.
Os imagináis un servicio
con 30 ó 40 médicos en una sesión clínica,
alguien que levante la mano y diga:
"¿Por qué no aplicamos a este paciente
el mismo tratamiento
que aplicamos a aquel hace dos meses?"
Ese silencio aterrador,
esperando la respuesta del jefe,
"¿Me está insinuando
que no sé cómo proceder con el paciente?"
Ya no hay más dudas, no hay más preguntas.
Por supuesto,
ya no se comparten conocimientos.
Por lo tanto, el equipo aprende menos.
Y como el equipo aprende menos,
comete más errores.
Y como comete más errores,
Amy Edmondson ha demostrado
que salva menos vidas.
El tercer elemento
que caracteriza a un hospital optimista,
son las políticas promovidas
por la alta dirección,
para fomentar la confianza
de los empleados hacia la institución.
Tiene que ver
con políticas de igualdad de oportunidades
con políticas de formación continua,
no solo en lo sanitario,
también en habilidades,
gestión de conflictos, oratoria,
todo aquello
en lo que los profesionales sanitarios
no hayan recibido formación.
Todas esas políticas tienen que aplicarse
con la máxima transparencia.
¿Os imagináis gestionar plantillas,
de 7 u 8 mil trabajadores,
que representan unas 180 funciones
dentro de un hospital,
que trabajan por turnos?
La transparencia y la comunicación
es muy importante.
Saber que todo el mundo
puede estar al tanto
y disfrutar de las mismas oportunidades.
Eso es complicado
y es uno de los rasgos característicos.
El cuarto elemento tiene que ver....
ahora es cuando me bloqueo.
Un aplauso, ¿no?
(Risas y aplausos)
Gracias.
Los jefes que no son jefes,
son líderes, la seguridad psicológica,
las políticas,
las políticas que generan confianza...
La cuarta, sigue sin aparecer...
Son las cosas del directo.
La quinta me la sé, eso está bien.
La quinta me la sé.
(Aplausos)
La quinta tiene que ver
con el elemento más mágico de todos,
tiene que ver
con la búsqueda de la misión.
Esa misión que hemos comentado
de nuestra empresa.
Ese "para qué", que nos ayuda
a aunar las voluntades detrás
de algo importante.
Me vais a decir:
"Es imposible en un hospital".
Sí es posible.
Es posible que la gente
haga algo para los demás
más allá de su rol.
Es posible que la gente
decida ayudar a un colectivo.
Una carrera para la investigación.
Un espectáculo
donde los profesionales sanitarios
se unen para actuar
a favor de una asociación de niños
con cáncer.
Una promoción de la salud
en las escuelas públicas.
Cualquier cosa con tal de ir más allá.
De hacer algo
más importante que ellos mismos.
Porque cuando sucede esto,
ya no hay etiquetas.
Ya no hay jefes de servicio.
El médico cirujano o el auxiliar.
Todas esas etiquetas caen.
Los roles desaparecen.
Aparecen personas que están codo con codo,
luchando por algo más grande
que ellos mismos.
En esos momentos, la comunicación mejora.
Cuando hay comunicación,
confianza y orgullo de pertenencia.
Así nacen los equipos de alto rendimiento.
Así nacen los equipos
de grandes cuidadores.
Sabemos que esto no es fácil.
Pero somos optimistas.
Ya lo sabéis.
Y cuando las fuerzas flaquean,
nos acordamos de la leyenda del colibrí.
La leyenda del colibrí
la cuentan los indígenas
de Sudamérica.
Y dice lo siguiente:
Todos los animales estaban en la jungla
y se desató un terrible incendió.
Todos los animales salieron huyendo.
Todos menos el colibrí.
El colibrí iba y venía
entre el lago y el incendio.
Tirando las gotas de agua
que transportaba en su pico.
Y en una de esas idas y venidas,
la jirafa le dice:
"Colibrí, ¿no te das cuenta
de que lo que haces no sirve para nada?
El colibrí miró a la jirafa y le dijo:
"Lo sé, pero yo estoy haciendo mi parte".
Así que nosotros en nuestra empresa
sabemos que somos unos pequeños colibrís.
Pero ¿sabéis que es lo mejor?,
que vosotros también podéis ser colibrís.
La única cosa que tenéis que hacer
es la siguiente:
mirar a los profesionales sanitarios
como lo que son,
unos superhéroes que nos cuidan
cuando más lo necesitamos.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)